My next question pertains to the tracking problem that we talked about in class.
In class we addressed a 1-dimensional tracking problem where we estimated the location of the system and its velocity.
I'd like now to generalize this to a 2-dimensional problem.
We'll be given coordinants x and y,
and the object we're tracking moves in 2-dimensional space,
and we wish to use a Kalman filter to understand where the object is, what its velocity is,
and even be able to predict a future location based on the estimate of the position and its velocity.
So the only difference, class, is that our object now moves in a 2-dimensional space,
where as in class, it moved in a 1-dimensional space.
So my first question is what's the dimension of the state vector in the Kalman filter? [Dimension of the state vector?]
In the class, it was this kind of state vector. Now, we have a new one.
How many dimensions or how many variables are there?